- The only thing I have
I ever wanted to be
for my whole life was a writer.
Creative living is any life that you live
where your decisions
are based more strongly
on your curiosity than your fear.
The definition of your
ego is it's a bottomless
hole of desire, it can never
be satisfied with anything.
You can't open a magazine today,
without somebody, the headline is always,
how so and so found balance!
For me, in my life, writing
is the thing that I love.
And the (bleep) sandwich
was the seven years
that I was not getting published.
With creativity, even my failures,
the stakes are so low.
Aside from people who are
very heavily medicated,
the calmest people that I know
tend to also be the wisest.
If you can't feel like you're alive
unless you're burning bridges behind you,
light the match, walk
away, that's your deal.
I'm operating constantly
at like 90 percent
fear threshold, I'm afraid right now.
- She's an American author, essayist,
biographer, and novelist.
She's best known for her book,
Eat Pray Love, which has spent 199 weeks
on the New York Times bestseller list.
Eat Pray Love was also turned into a film
by the same name in 2010.
She's Elizabeth Gilbert,
and here's my take
on her top 10 rules for success.
- The only thing I have ever wanted to be
for my whole life was a writer.
I wrote all through childhood,
all through adolescence,
by the time I was a
teenager I was sending my
very bad stories to the New Yorker,
hoping to be discovered,
after college I got a
job as a diner waitress,
kept working, kept writing,
kept trying really hard
to get published, and failing at it.
I failed at getting published
for almost six years.
So for almost six years, every single day
I had nothing but rejection
letters waiting for me
in my mailbox and it was devastating
every single time and every single time
I had to ask myself if I should just quit
while I was behind, and give up,
and spare myself this pain,
but then I would find my resolve
and always in the same way, by saying,
I'm not going to quit, I'm going home.
You have to understand that for me,
going home did not mean returning
to my family's farm.
For me, going home meant
returning to the work
of writing because writing was my home.
Because I loved writing
more than I hated failing
at writing, which is to
say that I loved writing
more than I loved my own ego,
which is ultimately to say,
that I loved writing
more than I loved myself.
And that's how I pushed through it.
My definition, personally of creativity,
is that it's the intersection
between a human's labor
and the mysteries of inspiration.
Which is kind of grand.
But my definition of creative
living is much simpler.
Creative living is any life that you live
where your decisions
are based more strongly
on your curiosity than your fear.
That's it.
And if you consistently,
habitually, routinely,
at every intersection and
decision in your life,
make decisions that are based
on curiosity rather than fear,
then you will be engaging with creativity
at some level, at some point.
And it won't look like my life,
it will look like your life,
it won't look like anybody else's life.
Because everybody's
curiosity is different,
so everybody's path of following curiosity
will have a different outcome,
but your life itself
will become a work of art
if you can consistently live that way.
Not easy, but so worth
it, so worth the trouble.
(laughs)
It's perfectly okay to have an ego,
we all have one, the
definition of your ego
is it's a bottomless hole of desire,
it can never be satisfied with anything.
Your ego is the thing that
will sell 20 million records
and wonder why it wasn't
30 million, right?
And it can be satisfied for moments,
but it can't be eternally satisfied.
No matter what your ego gets,
there's going to be another level
where it wants more,
it wants five of them,
it wants them in blue, it
wants it tomorrow morning.
We all have this, at
some level in ourselves.
So I had a letter on
Facebook the other day
from a young woman who said,
I don't think it's fair
for anybody to tell me
that I shouldn't want to
be a successful actress.
I'm going to acting school and I want
to be a successful actress.
And I said of course you want
to be a successful actress,
I wanted to be a successful writer.
When I was your age I
wanted to be published,
if I didn't want to be published
I wouldn't have bothered
trying to get published,
I would've just written
in my bedroom and put it under my desk
and been fine but I wanted
it to be seen, it's fine.
But, make sure you have,
if you're not capable
of having a stronger motive than that,
make sure you at least
have an additional one.
Make sure you have an additional one.
And let that additional one be something
that has more to do with
your soul than your ego.
Because you are also a soul.
And your soul wants a
bunch of different stuff
than your ego wants.
Your soul wants wonder, it wants becoming,
it wants unfolding, it wants
process, it wants connection,
it wants some sort of sense of meaning,
those are the things your soul wants.
And I have this lecture
with myself all the time,
so that when I get a bad
review and I'm miffed about it
and I feel like I've been misunderstood,
or worse, understood,
(laughs)
and revealed in a way
that I don't want to be,
I can see this difference
where I can check
in with my ego and my ego's wounded,
it doesn't like it, I would like everybody
to like everything I do, it hurts.
I still don't like it,
after all these years.
And I'll be like ouch,
that didn't feel good.
I didn't want that.
And then I check in with my soul,
and say, how you doing?
And my soul's like, we're
fine, can we play more?
Can we make another thing?
I just want to make another thing.
Let's do it again, let's do another one.
Let's do it differently, let's try this.
I can never totally circumvent my ego
but as long as I'm
making sure to constantly
check in with a richer and more
interesting part of myself,
then I feel like I'm alright.
- And let's throw out that word balance,
we're always trying to say
balance, and what is that?
- That is a word I would
like to see eradicated,
(laughs)
from the cultural conversation,
I mean you can't open
a magazine today without somebody,
the headline is always, how
so and so found balance,
how this person found balance,
have you ever met that
person, first of all,
and if you did, would you
want to even be friends
with them, is that somebody
who you'd want to call
in the middle of the
night when you've lost
your balance, balance is
something that you find
and lose, regain and
lose, we're on a planet
that's spinning 7,000 miles an hour,
our minds are spinning
20,000 miles an hour,
we're surrounded by
people who are in change,
we're in change, to expect that you should
somehow be able to hold your state
through that entire thing is just crazy!
Every pursuit, no matter
how glamorous it may seem,
no matter how exciting it feels to you,
no matter how much you feel
you were born to do it,
comes with a (bleep) sandwich.
So the question is not, what do I love?
The question is what do I love so much
that I don't mind eating
the (bleep) sandwich
that comes along with that thing?
So for me, in my life, writing
is the thing that I love.
And the (bleep) sandwich
was the seven years
that I was not getting published.
And that I was coming home from
my job as a diner waitress,
as a bartender, as an au
pair, as somebody who worked
at flea markets, as a
cook, and I was coming home
tired and smelling like
other people's french fries,
and sitting down and doing my real job,
which was to write, and
then to go to the mailbox
the next day and get
another rejection letter.
And then say, do I still want to do this?
Cause this (bleep) sandwich sucks!
(laughs)
- Am I ready to take another bite?
- And I did still want to do it.
And now, even as somebody
who makes their living
as a writer, there's no end
to the (bleep) sandwiches.
It's like, oh hello,
horrible review in prominent
newspaper, that's your
(bleep) sandwich today Liz,
you still want to do this work?
- [Interviewer] Yup.
- Yeah, I still do.
Still worth it.
Like, hello, awful comment on social media
from somebody who thinks
you're a pile of dog (bleep)
and has chosen every
possible way that they can,
just cannot get it out of
their system fast enough,
how much disregard they
have for your entire life,
still want to do this thing?
Yeah I still want to do it.
So that's the question,
because the first time
you encounter the (bleep)
sandwich, you're like,
well this isn't worth it.
Then that's not the thing
you're supposed to be doing.
And there are plenty of
things in life that I have
run into the (bleep)
sandwich and I've been like,
so not worth it, so not worth
it, I don't want to do this.
Like whatever the alleged
benefits of this thing might be,
no, the Soulcycle, no!
(laughs)
Like, I know it's probably
really good for me,
but I feel like throwing up right now
because this is too hard,
you'll not be seeing me here again.
And I love my sisters at Soulcycle,
I just don't like feeling
like I'm going to throw up
when I exercise, so it's not for me.
And that's the question.
So if you go into this thing thinking,
if I follow my bliss, and I live my dream,
and I stand in my truth, then
everything will be great,
it doesn't mean everything will be great.
It just means at the end of
the day when you check in
with yourself and you go, in the end,
on the balance, is this still
better than not doing it,
and the answer is still yeah,
this thing is still better
than not doing it, then
you're on the right path.
With creativity, even my failures,
the stakes are so low, you know,
this is the thing that I'm
always trying to tell people
about artistic endeavor,
the stakes are so low,
like very rarely is somebody going to die,
or have their heart broken,
or have their life upturned
because a poem that you wrote didn't work,
or an essay that you tried
to write didn't work.
If I write a book and
people don't like it,
they're not going to come
to my house and shoot me.
I'm exaggerating but I think sometimes we,
in the realm of creativity,
blow the stakes up
to something so much higher
than they possibly are.
I've heard a lot of comics say
that the fantastic thing
about doing stand-up
which I think is the
scariest of all art forms
is to bomb and then to walk offstage
and you're like, oh, that didn't work
and I'm still here, that's amazing!
The worst possible thing
that could happen, happened,
and nothing happened, I'm still intact,
I'm still in one piece,
so my creative failures
have that feeling to them where it's like,
wow that totally didn't
work, and I'm totally fine,
we're all going to
live, it's totally fine.
Look something happened to me,
but even saying that kind
of puts it in a little bit
too passive of a voice, I
set out looking for something
very specific and through
a pretty rigorous search
and a pretty rigorous set of practices
I got that thing that I wanted.
Which to put it really simply
and perhaps over simply,
is a certain calmness.
Life is an extremely
agitating event and I vibrate
at a slightly higher frequency
than is necessarily healthy
and I always have, I've
always been kind of anxious,
I've always been super emotive,
I feel things harder than is good for me,
indecision has been part of my life,
and I could see after
a certain age how that
was destructive not only to myself
but to people around me.
And I just think you get to a point
where you don't want to
be in other peoples' way,
you don't want to be taking
up other peoples' space
and energies to take care of you,
and I longed to be a
different kind of person.
I longed to be a little more at ease,
a little more relaxed,
and a little more wise,
because it seems to me
that wisdom is the beginning of serenity,
and aside from people
who are very heavily medicated,
the calmest people that I know
tend to also be the wisest.
Who are quickest or most
instinctively able to put things
in a perspective that takes
away the urgency of the moment.
And there are practices that
you can do to get there.
And those practices, as my
friend Richard from Texas
always says, the (bleep)
works, those practices work.
And people do it in
different ways and they do it
in different places, but
I think the end result
and the end desire is always the same,
you want peace, if not in the world,
then at least within your own mind.
If you can't feel like you're alive
unless you're burning bridges behind you,
light the match, walk
away, that's your deal.
- Fire it up.
- That's not the contract
that I've ever had
with my creativity because for me,
we live in this sort
of bumper sticker world
where the two bumper stickers
that I always want to edit,
with a sharpie, in the parking lot,
there's the one that says jump
and the net will catch you,
and there's the one that
said what would you do
if you knew you could not fail.
So the edits I want to make are,
jump and the net might catch you,
(laughs)
and what would you do even
if failure wasn't even
a word that you were caring about?
Which is a long edit and makes
for a terrible bumper sticker,
but what I'm getting at is I don't like
the ethic that says,
if you try really hard,
and you put everything into it,
you're going to get
eveerything that you want.
Because we're all grown-ups here,
so can we just say that
that may or may not happen.
You may or may not get
everything that you want.
You might put everything into something
and it doesn't work and that's okay
if you didn't mortgage your
house, risk your family,
empty out your IRA, and put yourself
in a really precarious situation
such that you can never do it again.
That's the other thing, such
that, you've been so battered
by how you set up your life
so that now you're so cornered
and strapped and anxious and shamed,
- Yes.
- that you just say, well
if that's what it feels like
to give 100 percent to
something, you can keep it,
I'm going to take nothing but safe choices
for the rest of my life and that's it
and you just shut down, right,
I never want to see somebody
put in that situation.
So the contract that I made with writing
when I was 15 years
old, and I lit my candle
and made my deal with the universe
and said I'm going to be a
writer for the rest of my life,
one of the promises that
I made to the work was,
I will never ask you to
support me financially,
I will support both of us.
I am a resourceful person,
my parents raised me
to be a worker, I will
do whatever I have to do
to pay the rent and you and
I will have a love affair
on the side of this that
is not contingent upon
monetization, and I have
watched so many creative people
murder their creativity by insisting
that they are not truly
creative unless their creativity
pays the bills, and if
it doesn't pay the bills,
which it might or might
not, or it might for a while
and then it might not, you
might go out of fashion,
your thing might change,
people might not want
that anymore, and all of
a sudden, you're stuck,
and I see those people go
into depression, bitterness,
rage, resentment,
you have to be childlike in the pursuit
of your life, but you cannot be childish.
And this is a really big difference.
Childlike means walking into the world
with wide open wonder and being open and
letting go of bitterness
and ready to be amazed,
ready to be taught, ready
for everything to be new.
That's childlike.
Childish means I want
it and I should have it.
I don't like the way this
turned out, it's not fair,
I'm going to have a temper tantrum now,
nothing ever goes my way, I didn't grow up
in the right family, I
don't have the right tools,
I didn't get to go to the right school,
nobody likes me, I quit,
and just because I want it
I should have it, that's childish.
So you have to separate those things out,
I believe you can be childlike
and mature at the same time.
And mature means looking after
yourself in the real world,
in a real way.
I write in seasons, and I'll
say that if anybody out there
is an aspiring writer as
everybody is and should be,
and I do always encourage
aspiring writers,
I would say, if you're at that level,
you should be writing
everyday because nobody else
will make you do it, you
have no incentive to do it,
nobody's waiting for
it, if you're unknown,
no editor is knocking on the
door saying there's a deadline,
you have to create your own deadlines,
your own motivation, your own
structure and your own time,
and I did that when I was
an unpublished young writer
but now at this point,
the way that I've evolved
as a writer is that it's
seasonal labor for me.
And there are seasons for research,
and there are seasons for
publicity as we're doing
right now once the book is finished,
there are seasons for writing,
there are seasons for editing,
there are seasons to pause,
and so now it goes on a cycle,
and right now I'm just beginning
the season of research for the next thing.
But I don't try to muddy my head by...
And also it's pointless and
it's kind of a waste of time
for me to write everyday if I don't have
a thing to write yet.
I need to go collect a lot of information
before I can actually put it together
and I'd rather have all that done
and then sit down and do
the whole thing at once.
I am inherently and naturally
an incredibly fearful person.
I'm operating constantly at
like 90 percent fear threshold,
I'm afraid right now, I woke up afraid,
I'm going to go to bed
afraid, I was born afraid,
I always sort of, been
tremulous with fear,
but my only saving grace
in my life is that I am
one percent more curious about the world
than I am afraid of it.
And that's all you need,
it just has to be one gram
more curiosity than fear, it's
not about eradicating fear,
it's not about eliminating
fear, it's not about this,
I think of a particularly American thing
that's going on right now
of this idea of like kicking
fear in the ass and punching
it out and showing it
who's boss, this kind of
extreme sports language
that a lot of people
are using around fear.
That doesn't work for me
because anything I ever fight
in my life tends to fight back harder,
so anytime I've ever tried to attack fear,
it just decides to show
me how much more powerful
than me it is and it just roars
to life in a much bigger way
so that whole war against
fear doesn't really work.
And so for me it's always been about,
what do I have that's
slightly stronger than fear
and for me it's just
about curiosity, wonder,
inquisitiveness, I'm terrified
to see what's on the other
side of that hill but I really
want to see what's on the
other side of that hill.
I'm terrified to see what
will happen if I try to do
this project, but I'm
also slightly more curious
to see what will happen
and oftentimes when my
fear arises, which it does nonstop,
I try to engage in a conversation with it,
and so the first thing I do is thank it,
which I don't think we do enough,
I don't think we show enough
gratitude to our fear,
all it's trying to do is keep you alive,
and save your life, so I
thank it for caring about me
and trying to protect me and
then I try to explain to it
what I'm doing and why
we're doing this and I know
that your job is to tell
me all the worst outcomes
that can happen, but I
really want to do this
and if it still won't back down,
I usually come to my fear and I ask it
for it's alternative suggestions.
Okay so I want to do this project,
and you, my fear, are telling me not to.
So what do you have to offer
me, what's your suggestion?
And when you challenge it like that,
the answer is always nothing.
It has nothing to offer,
it never has a better idea.
It has never once had a better idea.
It just doesn't want me to do anything.
It would just prefer that I stayed
in a darkened room with a cool
damp cloth on my forehead,
hiding from the world forever.
And that's not going to do it for me.
That's not an interesting
enough alternative.
And until my fear gives me a better idea,
than the cockamamie weird
jacked up idea that I have,
I kind of have to do the
cockamamie weird jacked up
idea because at least it's a thing.
Cause the alternative
is always do something
even though it might not work and people
might not like it and you
might not make money from it
and it might be strange
and it might be a disaster,
at least it's a thing.
The alternative that fear
always offers is a blank
piece of paper, I got nothing for ya.
Just don't, just shut
it down, just nothing.
And for me when the alternative
is so clearly between
something and nothing,
I'm just not nihilistic
enough to go with nothing,
I'm just curious enough to
have to go with something.
Which isn't a sort of act of
faith that it's going to work.
I had a letter recently
from a woman who said,
I think I'm about ready
to start writing my book
but I don't want to
start until I'm convinced
that the universe will give
me the outcome that I want.
(laughs)
I was like, yeah that is
never going to happen.
The universe might not
give you the outcome
that you want, we're not children here.
Like we all know, jump and
the net might not catch you,
(laughs)
but the universe will give you an outcome,
it's going to give you something,
you're going to know more about yourself
than you did at the beginning of the thing
certainly, it might
not be what you wanted,
it might not be what you expected,
but it'll be something, and always,
always, always given the
choice between something
and nothing, I'm going to
have to choose something.
- Thank you so much for watching,
I made this video because
Phoebe asked me to,
so if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you
want me to profile next,
leave it in the comments
below and I'll see what I can do.
I'd also love to know which of Elizabeth's
top 10 rules had the
biggest impact on you,
what lesson most stuck out for you,
leave it in the comments
below and I will join
in the discussion.
Thank you so much for
watching, continue to believe,
and I'll see you soon.
Oh, I'm great at boundaries.
I'm not great at boundaries, I'm kidding.
I so thought that was
going to be a laugh line,
I thought you guys knew me,
I thought you knew me well
enough to know that, what?
No, I don't have any boundaries,
I'm the permeable membrane, I don't know.
I'm a little better at
it, but I have learned
one important thing which is that you
sort of get to a point in
your life where you think,
I have to learn how to say no
to things I don't want to do,
and that's a big mature moment when you
start to begin to do that,
but the bigger mature moment
is when you learn how to say no
to things you do want to do.
Because you know that
you just don't have time
or you don't have energy or
you have to sort of triage
your life and there just
isn't an opportunity.
And that only came to me very recently
that sometimes you have to
turn down even the wonderful
things in order to take
care of your health,
or to take care of what
you truly, truly, truly
care about, not just what
you truly care about.
No catharsis ever happened
without somebody's participation.
People talk about cathartic experiences,
somebody has a horrible accident
or a horrible heartbreak
and it transforms them but
not without their assistance.
Not without them showing up for it.
And I think travel can always
seem like such a natural
way for people to change their
lives but it can't impose
change on you, you can only will it in.
And similarly, whatever
beautiful treasures
of selfhood that I found on this journey
are mine to lose any day I feel like it.
And so I consider it my obligation to hold
onto as much of that
as I can within reason.
I would so love to tell
you that I get up everyday
before dawn and meditate
and I'm half tempted
to tell you that because
how the hell would
you guys ever know if it's true or not
but in fact it's not true,
(laughs)
but I do it more days
than I don't, and I think
that for that I kind of base
it on my writing practice
as well, I would love to
say that I write everyday
but I don't, but I write
more days than I don't.
And I think as long as in
your life you're doing more
of what's beneficial to you
than not, then that's probably
good enough for what we
can do in our normal lives.
You can only make this decision
based on what you know today.
And so whatever you decide
to do, about this pregnancy,
about this person that
you're involved with,
about this situation that you're in,
all you know is what you know right now.
And the decision's
going to have to be made
based on that, so you are going to have
to pre-forgive yourself for
what you don't know yet.
And it may be that years
later, when you have
more information about your
life and about the world
you may look back on the
decision you made this day,
whatever it is, and you may
wish you had made a different
decision, but you have to begin right now,
forgiving yourself for
what you can't know yet.
I feel like that is the most compassionate
possible advice that anybody
could be given when they're
making a difficult decision in your life.
And then later, to go back
and look, cause we spend
so much time mired in regret,
about things we should have known,
things we should have done,
things we shouldn't have done,
and at some point there's this mercy
that you have to show
to yourself that says,
every decision I've ever made in my life
I made based on what I knew then
and that's all I had to work with.
You can't know something
before you know it,
it's just a rule of life,
and I think about some of the
stuff I've done in my life
and how stupid it was, and I look back
on a younger version of myself and think,
how could you have not known better,
and the only compassionate
and merciful response is,
because I didn't yet.
And maybe I had to do
that terrible stupid thing
in order to learn, so
that I could become a more
mature person who wouldn't do it again.
Maybe I had to do it 10 times!
Maybe I had to do it for 15 years.
Maybe I had to do it for 30 years.
But you're not going to learn
something until you learn it.
And then at that moment you
must, immediately, forgive
younger versions of yourself
for what she didn't know yet.
And you must, in advance, I
have to sort of look ahead
and know that when I'm
56, I'm going to look back
at myself now at 46 and be like,
how could you not have seen,
you can't see what you don't see yet.
I think what we're most
missing in our lives
both in the public level
and the private level
and in the personal level is mercy.
Just this sense of mercy.
We're all doing the best
we can with what we know
at any given moment and we
simply can not do better
than that, I can't, you
can't, your family can't,
the world can't, it's all we've got.
So be a little gentler with
yourself and with others
and with their mistakes as well.